y todo en la economía está basado en la
noción de la escasez de recursos que
significa escasez en el contexto
cotidiano significa que no existe
cantidad suficiente o ilimitada de algo
que las personas necesitan es decir
cantidad limitada de recursos los
ejemplos más comunes especialmente en
las clases de economía de los recursos
escasos son la tierra y con esto me
refiero a recursos naturales
la energía incluso podría ser el agua la
madera y también los metales obviamente
también se refiere a terrenos
podríamos representarlo en esta imagen
claramente vemos un terreno de cultivo
incluso podemos decir que la energía
solar que hace que funcione todo esto
entra en esta categoría de recursos
naturales otro tipo de recurso escaso
del que se habla mucho en las clases de
economía es el trabajo y el trabajo lo
asociamos inmediatamente con las
personas estamos hablando de la fuerza
de trabajo es decir hablamos de los
trabajadores y las horas de trabajo que
realizan no sólo físicamente también
intelectualmente aquí vemos una foto de
personas trabajando otro recurso del que
se habla mucho en el contexto de la
escasez es el capital el concepto de
capital puede ser un poco confuso al
principio pero se refiere a las cosas
que tienen las personas para fabricar
otras cosas para comprender mejor esto
pausa en el vídeo observen estas
imágenes y traten de encontrar las cosas
que se refieren al capital en estas
imágenes podemos encontrar varias
cosas que funcionan como capital hay
cosas obvias como estas herramientas las
cuales son un claro ejemplo de lo que es
capital y también estos edificios
construidos para albergar animales y
cosechas son cosas que alguien hizo para
ayudar a crear otras cosas también
encontramos cosas poco obvias como estas
líneas de corriente eléctrica alguien
las fabricó para ayudarnos a distribuir
energía eléctrica que a su vez se usa
para crear otras cosas este es otro
ejemplo de capital un cuarto recurso del
cual escucharán hablar en economía es el
saber cómo combinar los otros tres tipos
de recursos y a este le llamaremos
organización algunas personas también
hablarán de la tecnología como recurso
escaso pero organizar se refiere a cómo
combinar los demás recursos para obtener
algo mejor alguien decidió que este era
el mejor lugar para colocar estas
construcciones alguien tuvo que decidir
el mejor lugar para poner los postes de
electricidad alguien decidió qué cosas
cultivar aquí y cómo sembrar las en esta
parte alguien decidió qué tipo de
trabajo se necesitaba aquí qué tipo de
terreno y qué tipo de capital era
necesario para construir esta fábrica
el equipo necesario para fabricar lo que
sea que fabriquen aquí a esto nos
referimos cuando hablamos de
organización aquí lo importante es que
vean a su alrededor no hay una cantidad
ilimitada de terreno para un propósito
específico no hay una cantidad ilimitada
de recursos naturales energía madera o
ciertos metales tampoco hay una cantidad
ilimitada de trabajo solo hay ciertas
personas que pueden trabajar y no existe
una cantidad ilimitada de capital es
decir no tenemos una cantidad infinita
de edificios o de equipo y tampoco hay
una cantidad infinita de organización
hay cierta cantidad de energía y tiempo
que podemos usar para pensar en cómo
combinar todas estas cosas conforme
avancemos con los vídeos de economía
veremos la escasez de estos cuatro
recursos que aparecen una y otra vez nos
vemos en otro vídeo